lara trump as promised a member of the
trump family and former senior adviser
to donald trump joins us now uh larry
thank you for being on the program with
us tonight i'll just start with this um
have you spoken to the former president
how is he doing what is the attitude of
the family
i have spoken to my father-in-law i got
to tell you you know he's as shocked as
anybody i think for someone and anyone
quite frankly who loves this country and
believes in america this should shake
you to your core what has happened today
this is a very clear demarcation in the
history of america never before as many
of your guests have already talked about
will have we seen something
like this happen where an unannounced
raid by the fbi is conducted on a former
president of the united states think
about this if this is what they're able
to do to the former president of the
united states think about what they
could do to you to anybody in america
the the bottom line here is that these
uh documents that have been in question
have been everybody's been cooperating
everybody from my father-in-law's team
has been cooperating with the fbi with
any authority that asked for anything up
until now and there was no need to make
such a big scene to do something this
insane quite frankly
to a former president but i think
everybody clearly knows will what is
going on here this is about weaponizing
the justice system as it has been so
many times in the past against somebody
who you politically do not like they
detest donald trump not just on the
democrat side but the general
establishment because he's not one of
them because he doesn't play their game
they are terrified he's going to
announce any day that he's running for
president in 2024 and this is a very
convenient way to just throw a little
more mud on donald trump as though they
haven't already done enough this is the
same agency don't forget the fbi uh who
you know had falsified documents to get
fisa warrants to you know conduct this
entire sham russia hoax that the country
had to deal with for two years millions
of taxpayer dollars in our time that
we'll never get back to find what
absolutely nothing they've been trying
to shove january 6 down everybody's
throat in an effort to get people to
care about that and think that's the
most important thing in the world that
hasn't worked for them yet so here they
are heading into a midterm and heading
into a presidential election season
coming up where they know they have no
hope on the democrat side they have
nothing positive to show that they've
done for the american people so what do
you do you try to take out a guy who
hasn't even announced that he's running
yet but they're terrified of him on the
on the democrat side for sure but i'm
going to say it again in the general
laura uh you've spoken to your
father-in-law um therefore you have the
most immediate information of anybody
we've spoken with tonight
do does he know do you know why his home
was raided
he believes it's the documents in
question that uh you know everybody's
been really upset about from the white
house look my father in lies anybody
knows who's been around him a lot loves
to save things like newspaper clippings
magazine clippings photographs documents
that he had every authority will to take
from the white house and you know again
he's been cooperating every single step
of the way with the people that have
have questioned any of this and and i
know people have brought it up before
but you know look at hillary clinton the
33 000 emails that she just deletes that
are completely gone and nobody bats an
eyelash about it donald trump takes some
documents that he had every right to
take that every president does didn't
take antiques uh you know like hillary
clinton took out of the white house and
paintings apparently um but that is what
he believes and that's what you know i
think is at the bottom of all this and
the reason that they raided mar-a-lago
quite frankly
all right all right always good to talk
to you thank you for giving us that
firsthand perspective from inside the
family tonight
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight